hmm
um
okay
so
so
uh
okay
let me
you
oh
send you apart from jerusalem
oh
let's come back
no
reviews
does anybody know these two gentlemen if
you don't
let us know you shouldn't be here if you
don't
it's great to have you guys yesterday i
was very proud to
nominate judge amy coney barrett
to the united states supreme court she's
one of our nation's most brilliant legal
minds and
i think she'll do very well we're moving
along very quickly
tremendous unity in the republican party
it's the consequence of winning
elections which we did
very substantially both in the senate
and
obviously in the white house and i think
we're going to take back the house i
believe that very strongly kevin is
doing a fantastic job
and i really believe we're going to take
back the house and
we're all working very hard on that um
we have noticed some comments made in
the media about
my incredibly qualified nominee
amy the new york times said her religion
is not consistent with american values
she's catholic
it covers a lot of people it's a very
disgraceful thing to
say some of the comedians i don't think
they're comedians because
comedians are supposed to be funny
they're not funny like
at all they're nasty they're mean and
they think they're funny
uh someday hopefully it's in five years
but someday
when i'm not here they're going to be
off television
because their ratings which aren't very
good anyway but their ratings are going
to go down like you've never seen before
that includes a lot of others also in
fact i'm sort of waiting for the new
york times and the washington post
abc cbs nbc
cnn msdnc i'm waiting for them to
endorse me because if they don't
they're going to drop with a thud like
you know it was supposed to have
happened long ago
and then we won a race and it was a
great
it was a great victory and our i think
we've never had a more energized base i
don't think so nobody's ever seen
anything like it the rallies that we're
having are
incredible we call them protests they're
friendly protests
we don't want to call them rallies but
the
friendly protest rallies are have been
incredible
people i don't think anybody's ever seen
anything like it and this is
still long before an election this isn't
like the evening before
these are long before an election the
incredible crowd we had in pennsylvania
and virginia
uh in every state no matter where in
north carolina
florida no matter where we go we're
having crowds like nobody i don't think
anybody's ever gotten before ever
not even close there's a level of
enthusiasm in
iowa today with the tractors thousands
of tractors and
different states the boats thousands and
thousands of boats
voters for trump tractors for trump
farmers for trump
uh it's really been uh very nice to see
the level of enthusiasm i thought
though on the religious situation with
amy i thought we settled this
60 years ago with the election of john f
kennedy
but seriously they're going after her
catholicism i
will stand with her fight with her and
we will
make sure that these attacks stop
because they really
it's unprecedented they're basically
fighting a major religion in our country
this is
incredible fighting any religion
fighting
catholicism is just uh incredible that
they can be
doing it are you catholic
29 supreme court vacancies have occurred
during an election
year or before an inauguration
in every single instance going back to
george washington the president has
performed his constitutional duty
and nominated a justice and in almost
every one of these cases over the past
230 years
where the president and the senate were
the same party
but the justice uh as you know that
justice was confirmed
this is about two centuries more than
two centuries of precedent
and i think it'll continue i think we're
going to have i think it's going to go
quickly
actually and i think and again i don't
know if i've ever seen the republican
party more unified i think it was
probably even more unified
with the impeachment hoax actually when
they did the impeachment hoax i think
that was
which really turned out to be a hoax
because now you look at what's happening
with
the fbi and justice department if you
look at all of those
text messages uh emails that were sent
it we have been totally proven right
they spied in our campaign
and everybody knew it biden knew it
obama knew it
everybody knew it and uh the
lame stream media just uh you know
doesn't want to pick it up
although some have i will say catherine
herridge at cbs
has done a fantastic job on it we
appreciate that
but this is a major scandal this is a
scandal the likes of which nobody's ever
seen this is actually the biggest
political scandal in the history of our
country
and with the exception of
they just don't want to write about it
you should write about that kelly you
know you should write about it you
should write about it you should do
something on cnn about it
because it's the biggest single scandal
of our time certainly the biggest
political scandal perhaps in history
they uh they spied in our campaign
and then they tried for a coup that
didn't work out too well
and it turned out that if you read you
read the text that came out over the
last three days
it turned out that they were really it
was reversed it was
the dnc and the democrats that were
using russia
and related or unrelated
hunter biden got three and a half
million dollars from the wife
of the mayor of moscow why did he get
three and a half million dollars and
then he got
millions more than we thought from
ukraine and he got millions more than we
heard about
from china hunter biden where's hunter
so these are all questions that are very
very big on the internet the biggest
thing going on the internet is exactly
this
and uh we're gonna have to see how that
all turns out
but it turned out that we were right so
we went through two and a half years of
ruining people's lives like general
flynn and many others ruining their
lives
and it turned out to be just the
opposite it was the democrats that were
dealing with russia and other things
so hopefully our attorney general
and others working on this very very
hard very diligently will
uh it'll lead to something that will be
very important for our nation i think
it's very important for our nations one
of the most important things
a central issue of the 2018
midterm elections was the kavanaugh
confirmation and american voters punish
the democrats in the senate you saw
what happened we picked up two seats
again something that
hasn't been reported on very much but we
picked up two seats for their treatment
of
justice kavanaugh and expanded our
senate majority to confirm
supreme court justices which was great
and now democrats are really brazenly
attacking judge
barrett for again her faith mostly is
what i'm hearing for her
catholic faith and whether it's dianne
feinstein or anybody else i think they
ought to treat
religion with much more respect i think
it's a disgrace that they can do it
biden and the democrats are desperate to
distract from the real issues which is
that their party has been
taken over by socialists extremists and
probably communists i think it's beyond
socialism i think it's a step beyond
and could be many steps beyond if you
take a look
and then if they win they will nominate
justices who will destroy the american
way of life the american dream they will
destroy the american dream they'll
destroy america
to destroy the united states of america
your private right to own a firearm will
be totally eliminated
your guns will be confiscated your
ability to live by your
religious faith will be devastated
they'll abolish america's borders and
give government health care to
illegal aliens which will destroy our
health care system because so many
people will pour into our country that's
a tremendous incentive
on voter fraud uh as you know
uh hopefully there won't be a uh
a very big movement because hopefully
we're going to be
able to win i think we have the the
massive movement i think we're going to
have a tremendous tremendous victory
there won't be a transition because i
can't imagine we call it transition if
we win you know they talk about will
there be a friendly transition of course
they will but
we have a big problem and you see it
every day you see it happening every day
with ballots
we are gravely concerned about the
democrat assault on
election integrity in brooklyn 25
percent of mail-in ballots were ruled
and valid in june's democrat primary you
saw that
in a special election in new jersey 20
of the ballots were thrown out
and four people are now being prosecuted
for fraud
saul in the mailing bill of 35 000
mail-in ballots were rejected in
florida's primary and 100
000 were rejected in california and
that's just the beginning
a week after pennsylvania's primary half
of the counties were still counting
ballots and you'll be counting them here
because this is a much bigger version of
all of that
just last week a number of discarded
military ballots were discovered in
pennsylvania
all of the recovered ballots these were
ballots that were thrown out
had been cast for a person named donald
j
trump in wisconsin three trays of mail
containing absentee ballots were found
in a ditch
they were thrown in a ditch three trays
it's a lot
in north carolina voters are reporting
receiving two ballots
in the mail many many voters i hear it's
thousands but they're getting two
ballots
i wonder if those are democrat areas
because the word is they are
in iowa caucuses last winter you know
what happened there you all reported on
it i think very well
right you remember that it was not good
right but in iowa they still don't
really know who the winner was i think
they called somebody eventually but it
was
many many weeks later but they really
have no
idea that's being continuous to be and
that's little that's just this one that
continues to be
litigated in iowa
they can't run a simple caucus yet now
they're trying to radically write
election laws nationwide just weeks
before the presidential election i heard
in new york
today that governor cuomo wants to
try and simplify the ballast because he
thinks they're too complicated
and all of that i agree with him i think
that's good but you don't do that now
the balance is starting to come in and
you know it's not you can't do it now
it's too late
joe biden and the democrat extremists
support all of these efforts to ensure
election
integrity they oppose voter id think of
it
what do i do they want a picture they
have a picture for
almost everything nowadays but they
don't want to pick you you had a picture
to get into the democrat national
convention you had a card
with your picture on it did you know
that fellas you have a
to get into the democratic national
convention
you have a card and your picture is on
the bill
for wedding which is a very sacred
right uh
they want we want proof of citizenship
a social security number requirement
they don't want any of this to happen
and they want uh no signature
verification
they don't want to have a verified
signature so they want
none of the safety valves that you would
have think of it they oppose voter id
they approve
proof of they they oppose proof of
citizenship
they oppose a social security number and
requirements for social security numbers
it's a safety valve
and they oppose even simple signature
verifications they don't want to have
signature verification
they want to require all states to do
mail-in balloting right i call it
unsolicited some people call it
universal i think universal doesn't make
sense because nobody understands why
universal it's
unsolicited they want unsolicited mail
inbound network just send these ballots
to whoever you can think of
uh we had a case i guess in new jersey
you were reading to me where somebody
was sent
two ballots so they had slightly one was
uh had a hyphen in it the name and the
other one had a k
and they got two names and it's uh i
wonder if that person was a democrat
probably was and uh mailing of millions
of ballots to people who never asked for
them
so millions of people are going to be
get getting balanced who never ask for
the violence they don't want the ballots
or maybe they want them maybe they don't
nobody knows really this is really a
recipe for chaos so when you look at
what happened in iowa and again that was
run by very
smart people it was a very limited
election it was very small numbers we're
talking about
talking about doing that for the entire
nation and
you could forget about november 3rd
because you're going to be counting
these things forever
and it's uh very dangerous for our
country so
certainly transition we all believe in
transition we believe
not only in transition but very friendly
but when the ballots and when the system
is rigged
which it is obviously it is and
the only one that knows that better than
me are the democrats
and they go into closed rooms and they
must laugh like hell
at what's going on because these ballots
are being found and this is the
beginning
i talk about it now at the rallies all
these people are watching
eyes and ears thousands and thousands
tens of thousands
but there's no justification for these
extreme changes to the election law
and if you can go to the grocery store
you can have an id
with your picture on it to vote is so
important i mean it's just
so important so a lot of things are
going on very importantly though i think
very
very very importantly is when you uh
when you do your
reporting i think you had a report on
the fbi scandal because it's one of the
great scandals
in the history of our country and i
think people want to hear about it if
you look
at the internet you'll see how people
want to hear about it and they all know
about it
and it just makes the media look so bad
and there's so much reporting i could go
into it right now but i'm not going to
do that but it would be a tremendous
thing for the
mainstream media media two really sad
reporting i think your ratings would go
through the roof i really do because
people really are tired of this
fake stuff where you don't even talk
about it and
the biggest scandal certainly the
biggest political scandal in the history
of our country by
far bigger than watergate much bigger
than watergate
and they try and avoid it as much as
possible
it's getting very hard to avoid so we'll
take a couple of questions and you may
have a question for these two
very wonderful people brilliant
uh people from the standpoint of
politics i would say and law
and if you have anything for kaylee we'd
love to do that go ahead please
thanks sir um last wednesday
when you were speaking to the attorney
generals you said that you hoped
federal judges were watching what was
going on with mainland ballots
do you hope that amy tony barrett is
watching as well
i do i'm sure she is i think everybody
is i think everyone in the country i
think we've made it a very big issue
and it's an issue that the democrats
tried to get away with i don't think
they're getting
i mean so many reports now are phony
ballots you know that i don't know if it
would have been reported before
but all of these rallies those you know
with thousands of people last night as
you know
and we're in harrisburg pennsylvania uh
the night before we were in virginia
i mean those crowds are whether it was
35
000 or 30 000 those crowds are massive
and that's on very short notice all of
those people are watching
you know we have eyes and ears now that
we wouldn't have had if we didn't bring
it up
so no i'm sure she's watching and i'm
sure that everybody's looking at it i
think
i think it's just common sense go ahead
um
did you discuss the election with her no
i didn't
i didn't i just didn't think it would be
appropriate
and i've watched over the years as
presidents would
interview and talk and make a decision
on supreme court justice and
i was actually surprised they wouldn't
talk about various things like
roe they wouldn't talk about you know
things that
are very important they think it's
inappropriate to talk about it i don't
know that it's inappropriate but
i've gone by that custom go ahead philly
thanks sir
democrats are arguing that
acb puts in in danger um
not only uh roe v wade but a number of
other decisions
do you think that they are correct no i
don't know i mean you know
but i think she's going to rule on the
law i think she's going to
i think she's going to be a great
justice for many years to come but i
can't say they also bring up health care
i mean
obamacare is terrible it doesn't work
we've made
the best of it we got rid of the
individual mandate which is great
we protect people with we are going to
protect people with pre-existing
conditions
100 but if we can end obamacare and come
up with a much better
health care system that's much cheaper
much cheaper and much better which is
what we'll do
on the other hand if the court rules
against we will manage
the system better but don't forget we've
already essentially
gotten rid of obamacare because we got
rid of the individual mandate and it was
all based on that
so we've done a tremendous amount
because the individual
mandate was the most unpopular aspect of
obamacare you had to pay a lot of money
for the privilege of for the privilege
of not paying for bad
health care so that was a terrible thing
for people
and what we will do is if we are
fortunate enough to
get rid of the little remaining in
obamacare and again
individual mandate the way i view it
that's no older obamacare because that
was the central point and we won that
we've already won that as you know
but by getting rid of that it's
different it's a much different thing
the other thing we've done is managed
here's the story
it's no good it's too expensive it's bad
coverage you don't get your doctor you
don't get your plan all the things that
president obama said
you don't get and biden too by the way
if i didn't even i don't think he has
any understanding of it
but you don't get your doctor you don't
get your plan 28 times president obama
said
you get your doctor you get your plan it
turned out to be a lie so here's what
we're doing if we can
terminate we're going to have a much
better plan
and you will have your doctor you will
have your plan you'll have a lot of
things that you don't get with obamacare
do you you said this numerous times but
do you really believe that joe biden
will be on
any type of performance enhancing drug
ahead of the debates
or are you just joking no not joking i
mean
i'm willing to take a drug test i think
he should too because he's had a very
uneven i watched him with some of the
when he was with you know debating uh
pocahontas and
harris who treated him so badly but i
watched him
and he was out of it right and then i
watched him against
bernie sanders and he was okay i mean he
wasn't great
but he wasn't terrible he was okay
a far cry from the way he you know what
i'm saying i mean if you look at some of
those debates
i said there's no way he can continue he
can't continue
then all of a sudden he debated crazy
bernie sanders and you know what the
truth is he was
he was okay and i said how did he go
from there
with those horrible performances to
where he was
okay and i always joke but you know it
is true he was no winston churchill
in debating but he was fine and
people say he was on performance
enhancing drugs a lot of people have
said that a lot of people have written
that
so so let's take a look at it take a
look why don't you just check it
you can check out the internet you'll
see plenty of people say it
and whether it is or not doesn't matter
but
i would love to take a test and he can
take a test too
so we'll start with debate uh obviously
it is coming up
how are you preparing is somebody
playing joe biden in the debate with you
are you
doing debate prep at all and these two
gentlemen have been helping
[Music]
we have who plays by it for you i mean i
would say
maybe a combination of these two and
either one of them is
about five times smarter than sleepy joe
but we had a little debate prep before
we
came here i think this whole thing
though is the bay prep you know what i
do is do vape prep every day i'm taking
questions from you people all the time
i mean i've taken a lot of questions
from you over the
last number of years and he doesn't i
watched the way he was treated on
msdnc on friday i guess he did it live
and it was disgraceful it was an
embarrassment i know her and she's a
pretty tough reporter
the way she was helping him along with
us it was so obvious what was going on
she was helping him she was giving him a
question and then helping him to answer
the question
i know her very well she doesn't do that
it was embarrassing and people don't
talk about it
i mean play some of those clips play
some of those answers those
the answers that where he wasn't able to
give an answer and she's pushing him
she's pushing him they never do that
with me i can tell you
but i don't have the kind of problems he
has so
how many hours would you say you've
spent honestly it's a little time i mean
not a lot
i'm running a country i don't you know i
don't have the luxury i watched
other people over the years i watched
one sort of fairly recently not too long
ago
go into a cabin lock himself into a
cabin and he came out and he wasn't
very effective you know he had so much
so many things going on
sometimes you can go too much in that
stuff you know sometimes you can go too
much i mean look
uh i've had i've never debated before
but then i debated a lot
four years ago and if you look at the
polls
those polls have come out hundreds of
thousands of people in time magazine and
all of the different polls i think
there's about seven or eight of them
according to those polls i won every
debate every single debate
in the primaries and then one of debated
crooked hillary
i want to re-debate i mean this isn't me
i felt i did but this isn't this is the
polls
you had time magazine poll you had this
that and i guess they take them off
the internet or they get phone calls or
something but according to that i won
every debate
uh and i felt i did
but i understand the subject now chris
is tough
i hope that chris is going to be equally
tough on
joe biden but i watched the young lady
who i won't i won't
say her name but it was embarrassing the
way she was getting him along
so i just asked a question about drugs i
think it's something that will be
appropriate
because you can't have a president that
needs that kind of help
if you do have a president that needs
that kind of help when you've got a deal
with putin and you've got to deal with
president chief china and you have to
deal with
kim jong-un and by the way uh do you
notice there's no war going on with
north korea which everyone thought would
be in it about one week after
i came to be president they thought it
was going to happen immediately
no war um and that's saving
perhaps millions of lives not just you
know they were saying oh fifty thousand
people know millions and millions of
people could have died
one of the ones that's going to likely
everybody's going to talk about is
there's a new york times story that came
out about an hour ago
that says that when you came to the
white house you were paying about 750
a year in federal income tax they are
not releasing their
they're not publishing the tax returns
they're not showing that out there
they're saying
to protect their sources in your tax
return sir does that sound right you're
paying a couple
it's totally fake news made up fake
we went through the same stories you
could ask me the same questions four
years ago i had to litigate this and
talk about it
uh totally fake news now actually i paid
tax but and you'll see that as soon as
my tax returns are
it's underwater they've been under order
for a long time
the irs does not treat me well they
treat me like the tea party like they
treated the tea party
and they don't treat me well they treat
me very badly
you have people in the irs very they
treat me very very badly
but they're under audit and when they're
not i would be proud to show it but
that's just fake news the new york times
tried it the same thing they want to
create a little bit of a story a little
bit
they're doing anything they can not only
that's the least of it i mean
the stories that i read are so fake
they're so phony did they tell you this
was going to come out today
no i didn't know anything about it i
think somebody said they were going to
do a negative
they always do they only do negative
stories i don't think in the la
i used to get good stories in the new
york times when i ran for office and i
happen to be
conservative republican i don't think
we've had a good story they predicted my
loss four years ago
they then apologized for their bad
reporting then they predicted the
fbi and all of these things that's now
proven to be a hoax a complete hoax
they got pulitzer prizes along with the
washington post they should give all
those pulitzer prizes back because
everything was wrong i mean it was so
bad their reporting was so bad they were
wrong
it was exactly the opposite now there
are people that should get pulitzer
prizes
solomon carter i mean
they're not in the business of pulitzer
prizes but sean hannity got it right
lou dobbs got it right laura got it
right many people that tucker got it
right
there were many people that got it right
i don't know what they get other than a
great salary and great ratings i mean i
don't know what they get
jordan yes thank you on the new york
times story though
you have to understand that when
americans read that you may have paid
only a few hundred dollars in federal
income tax per year
that seems very low for someone who's a
billionaire
so much i mean they're saying i paid
nothing can you give people
an idea how much you actually are paying
yeah basically well first of all i paid
a lot and i paid a lot of state income
taxes too
uh the new york state charges a lot and
i paid a lot of money at state
uh it'll all be revealed it's going to
come out
but after the auditors after the i'm
being
they they're doing their assessment
we've been negotiating for
a long time things get settled like in
the irs but right now when you're under
audit
you don't do it you don't do that so
we're under audit
but the story is a total fake and all of
this or is this one you know we had the
same exact questions usually asked by
the same people
and that took place four years ago you
remember this was so well litigated
it's incredible if you look at
the filings i have i think i have 108
pages of filings for all these different
companies that
do very well obviously because the
filings nobody talks about that
you'll learn much more if you look at
those filings and we have to file every
single year
but you'll learn much more if you look
at those filings those filings are very
complete
they're very big they're very powerful
they're very accurate and those are the
filings that you'll learn much more
and when it's done but when you're under
audit
you just don't release them and again
they treat me they treat me
they treat me that was what you paid in
federal funds
i'm talking to him you should be more
respectful of this gentleman you're very
rude to him
but i will tell you that i look forward
to releasing
that i look forward to releasing many
things i'm going to release many things
and people will be really shocked
but the new york times has been doing
fake story after fake story
i've never seen anything like it and
people understand it
and people that's why the the media has
such a low
approval rating now because of what
they've done it's really a shame they're
going
back to yeah thank you mr president uh
two questions
if you have any questions for these two
i was going to ask both you
and governor christie and mayor giuliani
your two guests are practicing catholics
you've talked about
possible bias against judge barrett's
religion
only two catholic bishops have come out
to say the same thing you have is any
effort being made by any of you to say
yet the us conference
of catholic bishops i think that uh
these other uh leaders we're in the
process of doing that
i think it's horrible what they're doing
i mean they're playing
the religious guard and it's frankly
you're talking about catholics
that's a very major religion in our
country
i don't know chris you have anything to
say about it
it's obvious what they're doing so you
know she'll be strong
she'll be tough and she'll stand up for
what she believes and she went through
just like i did four years ago in terms
of litigation of different things
she went through it before and did very
well rudy what do you think
i think the article in the new york
times today
reveals a very strong anti-catholic bias
i mean it says in the article that
catholicism and the american ethos
can't be uh contradict each other
that's a horrible thing to say and then
it says that catholics have difficulty
separating public and private morality i
i don't have difficulty separating
public and private morality
so what i see is the beginning of a
really strong
anti-catholic attack and having lived
through the john kennedy
election that article today reminded me
of the things that used to be written
before john kennedy could a catholic be
loyal
to the united states come on well having
said that exactly what feinstein raised
right when she made that awful remark to
uh to
to the judge well let me repeat my
question again why are only two bishops
within the church speaking out and will
you make an effort
to get the u.s i think they'll come out
first this is day one
i mean we've just started this this is
absolutely day one and
you know i mean they're going to be
coming out very strong the catholic
church is very well united on this
they are so thrilled that amy was chosen
they are so thrilled oh they'll be
you know again it's been 24 hours okay
so it's been a very short period of time
but they're going to come out very
strong yeah please go ahead oh yeah
christina from oh yeah thank you for the
briefing um you spoke earlier about some
of the subjects that
joe biden has been refusing to answer
questions on specifically hunter biden
his involvement with russia
ukraine even china and the press doesn't
ask those questions it's incredible
i'm wondering the debate is coming up
this week do you anticipate joe biden
being held a task and will he be able to
answer those questions
i don't know i mean we're going to find
out because a lot of things are going to
come up in the debate
that may be one i mean the son didn't
have a job he
uh had some big difficulties and then
all of a sudden he's making millions of
dollars
as soon as his father becomes vice
president no i think that'll come up i
don't think
i don't think joe can answer it frankly
i think
there's only one reason he made all that
money and then you have to say what
about joe's involvement then
why did joe not give the billion dollars
over to ukraine as an example
until such time as they let go of a
prosecutor that was investigating the
company that his son was involved with
i mean there's some bad questions i
don't think they have answers
and if we had a media that was fair
even just reasonable this would be the
biggest story
for years and years and years then you'd
really be entitled to real pulitzer
prizes not the fake committee that gives
you these fake awards
so i mean it's a really fair question
but
it's hard to believe when you see the
kind of money that
he has made from china from russia
where the wife of the mayor of moscow
gives him
three and a half million dollars and
nobody even has any question about it
why did he get three and a half million
dollars
i'll tell you why because joe biden was
in on it joe was in on it
there's no way that he wasn't and uses
joe biden's plane
air force two uses joe and they go to
china and then he comes back and
he never mentioned it to his father that
he just got a billion and a half dollars
and now it's turning out
that it's much more money than that
rooney it turned out to be much more
money from china they have a member of
the chinese communist party gave him a
lot of money
and the press has no interest in these
stories it's
it's just uh it's very disheartening for
the people of our country please the
president
if he tries to dodge the questions or
doesn't address them head-on are you
prepared with the facts and
um information to answer that for the
americans well i have all the
information
it just came out i mean i didn't know
about moscow three and a half million
dollars from
the mayor's wife i didn't know about
that and he's a very influential
powerful man
in russia as you know and it wasn't me
i didn't have anything to do with russia
that came out loud and clear what also
came out is they should have never gone
into this fake
mueller investigation and it also came
out that the 31 phones that were wiped
clean shouldn't have been wiped clean
and that's a criminal act
and bloomberg likewise shouldn't be
paying for prisoners to go in florida
and
go and vote because he's basically
paying which is totally illegal
going and paying prisoners i hope he
hasn't done it yet but he's down in
writing is doing it this is what he
wants to do
so that he can ingratiate himself to the
democrats after they made him look like
a total fool in the debate
i mean what they did to him is
incredible and that he goes out and
spends money
it shows you the problems that he's got
mini mike
but for him to go out and buy votes
because that's i don't know
you're a very good lawyer are you
allowed to go tell people that go vote
i'm going to pay you off your team
can't buy votes that's for sure yeah
because that's what it is i mean it's a
it's a very serious very serious charge
uh yeah please go ahead
um mr president
and the civilians are killed and
according to the officials
from the azerbaijan they say the first
shoot came from the armenian what's your
comment on this so we're looking at it
very strongly just happened and
i know about it i learned about it today
and
yesterday and we're looking at it very
strongly
we have a lot of good relationships in
that area we'll see if we can stop it
okay thank you very much mr president in
10 of the previous 15 years before the
2016 election you played zero dollars in
income tax you disputed that
appropriately 50
mr